[Música]
en casa o en el estudio de pan que
habría encabezado igual esta crónica
puede que cai manuel y toma amigos desde
la escuela hayan colgado sus cascos pero
siempre serán una herencia colosal
llevaron ese riff house y electro
denostado con voces vocoder izadas a la
corriente principal y el gran público
mutando la música de los 90 y lo
hicieron con un toque frames que activó
la electrónica del país al mundo pero lo
mejor fue su revolución en su caso ser
coherentes y artísticamente
irreprochables desde su formación hasta
su separación
sabemos que el lucro gótico los
caracterizó dentro de una atención a lo
humano pero este anonimato común en el
género no iguala lo que supuso su primer
álbum de 4 home works desde el que
fueron cuidando texturas del pasado y
del futuro si esto es un epílogo al
epílogo con el que se autodestruyen tras
28 años de carrera y seis grammy porque
es difícil decir adiós a quienes además
recrearon el anime en películas y
videoclips volaron conciertos con
pirámides de leds e influenciar on con
su sonido a artistas como gorilas babe
inquieta
y que ni webs
los artistas decidiendo su futuro es lo
normal lo extraño es que una cantante
como britney spears carezca de ese poder
no solo por sus actos sino porque
fallamos como sociedad la princesa del
pop lleva 12 años bajo control de su
padre en una tutela recién dividida en
lo financiero con un fondo de inversión
elegido por ella spears no puede firmar
documentos usar su dinero o salir de
casa sin permiso pero esto que cuentan
de new york times' y fox apoyados por un
movimiento que pide su liberación gana
peso cuando detalla en su carrera un
pozo de años de misoginia y maltrato
psicológico con medios que la usaban de
productos sin valorar su salud mental
puede que la artista cayera en drogas o
perdiera la custodia de sus hijos pero
esta pieza nos retrata a nosotros ya lo
que permitimos antes del mito
[Música]
el documental tiene algunas ausencias
como la de su padre jamie spears pero
nunca tan notables como las que presenta
exhibió en 'la en versus farrow sobre el
presunto abuso sexual del cineasta a su
hija adoptiva dylan no hay voces
contrapuestas los testimonios responden
a la actriz y ex pareja mía farrow sin
explicar por qué de nueve hijos sólo dos
aparecen cómo fueron esos abusos
desestimados por varios entes o cuál fue
su reacción real al conocer la relación
de su otra hija sunny con alguien porque
verlo entonces uno porque es la versión
de una parte aunque no cumpla con
decirnos lo que esconde la punta de ese
icebergs y dos porque permite
reflexionar sobre la victimización entre
dos personas de poder y las condenas
mediáticas incluso a actores ligados a
alen y nada de esto se trata de forma
crítica
[Música]
y
y mientras el cubito aún mantiene
cerrados muchos museos en francia las
galerías de arte se han propuesto un
renacer aprovechando que son comercio no
esencial permitido porque cuando
pensamos en ellas pensamos que son
inaccesibles o costosas y ahora como
único oxígeno artístico se han decidido
a democratizar su espacio y romper esos
clichés
obras de arte público a primera vista
nos creeríamos en un museo en esta
galería en parís hay 350 metros
cuadrados de obras de renombrados
artistas entre las que perderse su
coloración es un consuelo porque extraño
mucho ir a los museos las galerías
siguen abiertas porque no aprovecharlas
contra todo pronóstico al espacio templo
no le ha ido mal en pandemia teníamos
mucho miedo de que el mercado del arte
sufriera una gran recesión pero por
ahora nuestros ingresos se mantienen
estables en comparación con 2019 lo que
es sorprendente esta galería más
intimista está exhibiendo una colección
fotográfica de jean-michel de noar aún
sin turistas han llegado caras nuevas
personas que nunca solían venir a las
galerías han comenzado a asistir pero es
poco consuelo cuando se trata de
planificar el futuro en un año 8 de 10
galerías en francia han registrado una
caída en su facturación en particular
las más pequeñas han tenido que
solicitar ayudas del gobierno cuando son
un salvavidas para los artistas que
producen puede tener un impacto muy
peligroso en los artistas porque si se
vende menos arte ellos tienen menos
ingresos y si las
cierran menos artistas centran su
trabajo en exhibición hasta ahora los
fondos estatales de emergencia han
ayudado a las galerías a mantenerse a
flote de todos los sectores culturales
golpeados por la pandemia los marchantes
de arte están lejos de ser los más
afectados
[Música]
sin tiempo en el calendario febrero
remata con dos discos uno 100 auténtico
de la australiana estás santana un
talento vocal y del beat boxing capaz de
tocar hasta 10 instrumentos mientras
canta su segunda composición alcanza
además la tierra firme del
autoconocimiento
[Música]
o sea
más mientras que hace tan ganas se
bautiza oficialmente como el madrileño
con 14 temas plagados de voces distintas
a me dejaste de querer abraza brasil con
toquinho y el conosur rockero con jorge
drexler y andrés calamaro y su tour
continúa con el boricua josé feliciano y
los rumberos gipsy kings entre otros
antes estaba saliente aunque está claro
da funk cierra el círculo iniciado
aunque sabemos que el devenir del dúo
son producciones por separado ya están
en ello
escuchémoslos cuantas one more time'
hagan falta cuídense y muchas gracias
[Música]